un premio Nobel de la Paz Al activismo
post soviético opositores rusos y
bielorrusos y Defensores de Derechos
Humanos ucranianos en kiev los
ciudadanos celebran el galardón para el
centro para las libertades civiles
Ucrania se ha ganado el respeto de la
comunidad internacional es señal y creo
que no será el último reconocimiento
como bien dice este señor el mundo Mira
a Ucrania Ya que ellos que hacen
oposición en Rusia Y belarús lo
demuestra el tuit de Enhorabuena del
presidente de Francia Emmanuel macron el
premio Nobel de la paz honra a los
defensores inquebrantables de los
Derechos Humanos en Europa artesanos de
la paz saben que pueden contar con el
apoyo de Francia distinta es la opinión
en belaruz después del premio para el
activista bielorrusoales vialiavsky así
habló en Twitter el ministro de
exteriores anatoly glass
en los últimos años una serie de
decisiones fundamentales y estamos
hablando del premio de la paz del comité
del Nobel sean politizado tanto que
disculpe Alfred Nobel se revolcaría
atormentado en su tumba pero la
oposición no solo viene desde los
aliados de Rusia de forma sorpresiva mi
High lo puedo liak asesor del presidente
bolodo y mercedeski protestó por el
galardón
la organización rusa esto cuando el
presidente ucraniano borodimir zelenski
Era uno de Los favoritos de la gente
para recibir el premio
el comité del Nobel tiene una
interpretación interesante de la palabra
paz y los representantes de dos países
que atacaron a un tercero reciben un
premio Nobel juntos
el Nobel de la paz 2022 se ha anunciado
en el día del cumpleaños del presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin y después de que el
año pasado un periodista enemigo del
kremlin Dimitri murat también fuese
galardonado